hi my name is Hana I'm an engineer on
the Android project and I'm here today
with Diane and Jeff also engineers on
the Android project and we want to show
you a couple of demos that demonstrate
that you can extend and replace existing
key components of the system because we
believe that all applications on Android
systems are created equal so then we'll
start by showing you an application she
wrote with the current public SDK so one
of the basic parts of the phone user and
pace is picking ringtones Android comes
with a fairly simple green tone picker
it goes unless you pick between a bunch
of stand ringtones on the phone I want
to write something that lets you do a
lot more so on this phone I've installed
my application now when you go and bring
up the ringtone picker it lets me pick
my application to run and why I selected
here I see my more sophisticated user
interface that lets you do a bunch of
things what I'm going to do here is pick
the music on my phone it shows me all
the music on my phone I can pick one of
these songs like that that sounds good
hit OK and now that's my new ringtone
now Jeff is going to show you other
things you can do to extend applications
on the phone thanks Diane one really
cool thing about Android is you can
create shortcuts on the desktop but you
can't create shortcuts to everything so
I wrote any code that lets you create a
shortcut to anything in the system to
create a new shortcut with any cut just
long press on the home screen select any
cut here you have a list of things you
can create shortcuts to one of the most
popular ones is direct call to tap here
and it launches contacts to get a list
of who you have phone numbers for select
one let's say row man click OK and now
we'll call tour man is just one tap away
tips are so does how to add exciting new
features to existing applications and
then showed us how to replace simple
components on the system but because we
strongly believe that all applications
are created equal we even let you
replace key components of the system for
instance the home screen I have here a
phone on which I downloaded the new home
screen from the Android Market you can
see its page here so now when I press
the HOME key I have the choice between
the old home and the new home screen so
because I prefer the new one I just
click on it and I'm presented with a new
experience that I prefer so we hope that
this demos demonstrated that you can
customize your user experience by adding
new features or replacing the existing
feature on Android
you